c'est une nouvelle étape franchie par m6
dans la course à la jeunesse et pas des
moindres ce soir la chaîne a décidé de
monter d'un cran en proposant un nouveau
programme intitulé objectif 10 en moins
présenté par la reine de la mode
cristina cordula cette fois ci pas
question de se contenter de changer sa
garde-robe pour se sentir plus mieux et
jolie ce soir christina propose un
changement radical et définitif
en soumettant les candidats de son
programme à une ribambelle de
spécialistes coiffeurs maquilleurs coach
sportive dans this dermatologue
mais aussi des professionnels en
médecine esthétique car c'est la came 6
compte faire la différence en proposant
à leurs candidats d'avoir recours à des
pratiques médicales pour améliorer leur
apparence
un pas que la chaîne est l'animatrice
semble franchir avec fierté une
banalisation de l'acte médical qui se
poursuit en seconde partie de soirée
avec un documentaire intitulé ils ont
choisi la chirurgie esthétique une
volonté visiblement affichée de la part
de la chaîne de normaliser ses
interventions chaque année plus de cinq
cent mille français ont recours à la
chirurgie esthétique 24 % des femmes
l'ayant choisi ont entre 50 et 64 ans si
le prix d'une injection peut varier
entre 300 et 600 euros
les opérations s'élève quant à elle à
plusieurs milliers d'euros alors êtes
vous pour ou contre la banalisation de
la chirurgie esthétique à la télévision
alors pour ou contre vous avez des
pancartes nous avons sa base sara
martins bonsoir
il avait 28 ans
28 ans vous êtes adepte de la logistique
vous avez recours depuis combien de
temps
aujourd'hui ça va faire six ans sa
première intervention que j'ai fait
j'avais 22 ans est la première
intervention que j'ai fait ça a été ma
poitrine parce que c'était un vrai
complexe pour moi déjà je n'avais pas du
tout pas traîné pour moi c'était quelque
chose qui est important et
et j'ai eu aussi menée sur lequel
j'étais très complexée alors là
franchement je vous regarde y'a rien qui
choque pas franchement c'est bien
aleri honnêtement c'est peut-être les
deux peut-être les dents un peu blanche
tamadone gouverneur moi et ma demande de
dons alors al'inverse on à anaïs qui a
70 ans d'antan qui est en coulisses
bonsoir is vous m'entendez allez y sont
là mais c'est ok alors à 50 ans vous
avez fait un l'ipo lifting aux paupières
café est en fait le lit politique s'est
mal passé un très mal passé alors on a
on à moi je comprends que vous dit
préférer être comme ça on a quand même
une photo de vos yeux ça c'est le avant
chez peau douce et le après off ted
après celle d'après oui et non donc
voilà il salue une captation une
catastrophe mais c'est la vie sans
toujours faire carrément et moi qui dois
faire alors mais après vous avez des
retouches
c'est à dire un banc début on m'a dit ça
va dégonfler tout se passe très bien
j'ai attendu six mois malheureusement à
force de me regarder bas je me retrouve
plus j'ai complètement changé je suis
moi quoi
et là je suis retourné voir le
chirurgien les juillet dit écoutez
regardez j'ai un problème il me dit bon
c'est pas grave c'est un petit quine
petites retouches et dont vous avez la
repousse et c'était encore pire
comment ça a été vécue dans votre
famille parce que je suppose que là
c'est que ces comptes parce que parfois
on dit pas sa famille part d'apple bah
oui non mais
j'ai très mal vécu cette opération qui
m'a été décrite comme un anodin
donc j'avais totalement confiance aux
chirurgiens s'était insurgé inconnu oui
oui et oui bah il faut aimer son nom à
chaque fois j'en dis qu'on aime sa
compagnie dans ta ala mais là mais là
maintenant c'est quoi vous mettiez
beaucoup vous vous sentez plus chez vous
mais moi je suis suivi par un psychiatre
depuis 2006 à six jours je suis sous
prozac
ah oui et non c'est donc les
conséquences désastreuses on passe à
côté
oui bah c'est la descente aux enfers
jusqu'à aujourd'hui je suis pas encore
indemnisées donc je me bats toujours
double thème du coup anaïs et c'est ce
que vous des émissions qui arrive en
france et qui vont parier sur dix avoue
savourer volts ou pas ou contrat vous
sait combien le monde a savouré volts
pourquoi est tout simplement les
personnes qui sans un novice qui
connaissent pas vraiment la chirurgie et
faire confiance aux médecins le même
chirurgien lui il est là juste pour
faire de la chirurgie d'années de
l'argent et ils sont pas avertis des
conséquences
ah ouais bah ça cela avant après et yvon
elle était jeune et qu'est ce que la
question était vraiment raison qu'est ce
que parce que quand on voit en photo
avant et qu'est ce qui vous a poussé à
faire cette l'ipo une épaule c'est à
dire tu le rythme de la vie les horaires
la fatigue avait trois enfants
et en plus de ça moi l'homme travaillé
ça allait beaucoup de personnes j'avais
beaucoup de contacts
donc les trucs qui se trouvait un dents
sur les paupières
on a dit qu'on pouvait les combles et
puis vous allez être en pleine forme
teixeira que j'étais va le sur rien et
je lui ai demandé m'a dit bon c'est un
geste anodin ça risque absolument rien
sarah donc vous vous avez effectivement
eu recours à la chirurgie esthétique
quand vous quand vous entendez anaïs
apparemment ça a été un désastre des
conséquences psychologiques
c'est compliqué de réparer les
vraiment les erreurs donc l'edhec la
marche arrière n'est possible ça vous ça
vous vous dites que vous quoi c'est vous
seul les colons s'est fait partie de la
séance à part ça c'est jaune artistique
donc y avait donc des facettes ça c'est
une chose sa venue le basique très mal
conseillé
mais assez souvent qui a fait des
facettes pas du tout aimé
attends je posais comme ça c'est pas
basique pour vous c'est basique mais moi
j'ai dit basique c'est pas que c'est
normal et que moi c'est devenu basique
on en voit de plus en plus ça que je
veux dire c'est à dire qu'avant c'était
pas du tout connu avant l'été de
couronnes et les courants ne savait
vraiment une finition pas du tout la
même c'est des grosses dents qui vous
mettez ce n'est pas beau du tout moi par
exemple j'avais dans qui se chevauchent
et c'était moche très moche et quand
j'étais jeune au collège plusieurs fait
pas peur de danton le témoignage de ces
importants à ce qu'elle dit parce que ok
il ya ce côté là qui est bénéfique pour
une femme qui est complexé qui peut
voilà justement permet de se décomplexer
mais elle cotait aussi la descente aux
enfers quand vous tombez sur des
changements qui ne sont pas bons et ça
existe malheureusement c'est ce qu'on
peut faire c'est vraiment trouver le bon
chirurgien mais comme alors comment on
était attendu ce moment c'est pourtant
lui il ya beaucoup de forums aussi qui
existent où il dénonce justement ces
chirurgiens qui ont fait des
catastrophes
et ça c'est très important et maintenant
après une fois que vous trouvez votre
beau chirurgien vous devez sentir au
sein de feeling avec lui et pas se jeter
à les faire votre survie comme ça parce
que deux décennies franchement dans la
paroisse géorgien s'est passé vraiment
non je parle pas de moi j'arrive sur ça
de quoi ce que je dis c'est trouver
vraiment le bon chirurgien ces avis
demandé voilà savoir c'est vraiment le
bon je l'agressé celui qui paye bien de
tous les risques encourus et dont il
rêvait mais c'est vrai général vous
savez que c'est une esthétique générale
impute un enfant doit regarder c'est
regarder l'émission de m6 de ce soir le
dock
le doc sur la chirurgie regardez
c'est un problème ça
[Musique]
les désirs
résultat j'ai un gros doute et je paye
mystikal douleur ça va être en fait
avaler vous inquiétez pas
il va
sur le moment
juste envie de s enfuir
attention
peut changer la vie de la patiente
[Musique]
serrez les fesses
s'ouvrir
la travail
ouais
je sais pas si j
oui moi ce qui me gêne pour répondre à
votre question c'est que la m6 sur toute
une soirée
de mon point de vue mais je vais
attendre de regarder fait l'apologie de
la chirurgie esthétique
moi j'ai rien contre mais ça peut être
dangereux il faut des contradicteurs
et là il ya toute une soirée pour dire
peut-être allez-y faites de la changer
ou non fait une émission de
divertissement et après on vous explique
pourquoi que c'est dans un but là est ce
que c'est vraiment du divertissement non
mais entre la première édition et
divertissement oui c'est du vandalisme
en moi je pense que au moins je suis oui
à la chirurgie esthétique non à la
banalisation et vous disiez tout à
l'heure justement la banalisation à la
télévision parce qu'avant on n'en
parlait pas parce que la télévision
reflète la société aujourd'hui dans la
société
c'est un tabou qui a sauté tout le monde
part de la chirurgie esthétique
même ici dans l'est parmi les chroniques
notamment dit je me suis fait ça alors
qu'avant c'était c'était oui avant
c'était tabou lesquels magali berda tout
le monde en parle a par exemple et jeudi
à dernière chose souvenez vous de la
série nip tuck
c'est une série qui passe et la fiction
c'est de la fiction mais ça a beaucoup
contribué à la banalisation relation vie
ascétique la fiction qui était diffusé
sur la télévision et c'est pour ça qu'on
arrive à 69 ans